je dois frapper comme un roc
dur comme une pierre de marbre
je suis fait de chair de viande
je suis né un matin à la pause un
jour j'ai attrapé mon fardeau et je suis parti
je mesurais six pieds je pesais 44 livres j'ai
eu un  le talon qui démange et je vise à me
déplacer je dois frapper comme un rocher et un cœur
comme une pierre de marbre
je suis fait de viande j'ai une chanson dans mon
pauvre bras droit
maintenant je suis gros dans le mal mais je ne veux pas dire non
dommage je suis fait de viande et je suis
gros comme l'acier doit courir autour de l'âme
et un moteur guérir nos mots et se promener
de ville en ville il n'y a pas d'homme qui peut
m'épauler j'ai une tête comme un
du roc et un cœur comme un caillou
je suis un pot de viande fait j'ai du sel dans ma
piscine en ce moment
je suis grand au lit mais je ne veux pas de
mal je suis fait de viande et je suis  gros
comme l'acier dois courir autour de l'âme et un
talon qui démange je mots et divagations de
ville en ville il n'y a pas d'homme peut
m'épauler je dois frapper comme un
rocher
et un cœur comme une pierre de bouteille
je dois frapper comme  un rocher
et des
pierres
il y a une vieille ballade d'iris appelée
male malone
dans la
belle ville de dublin
où se trouvent les filles
et elle
brandit une brouette
dans les rues
larges et étroites
cristal
elle était poissonnière et le destin n'était pas
étonnant
car son père et sa mère
étaient
aussi des poissonniers
et  ils manient
et muscles
vivants
et elle est morte
d'une fièvre
dont personne ne
pouvait la soulager
et ce fut
la fin de la
douce molly
malone
maintenant son fantôme
fait rouler son baril
dans
les rues
et les muscles
vivants
coco
et les muscles
vivants
alors
maintenant voici une chanson sur
deux des personnes les plus dangereuses au
monde
c'est un homme et une femme
et les noms de frankie et johnny
maintenant frankie et johnny
étaient amoureux
oh mon dieu comment ils pouvaient aimer
juste vouloir être fidèles l'un à l'autre
tout aussi vrai que les étoiles au-dessus
de lui  était son homme
mais il a
fini
maintenant frankie elle était une bonne femme
comme tout le monde sait
qu'elle a payé cent dollars
pour chaque costume de vêtements de johnny
elle aimait cet homme
mais il lui a
tout fait
maintenant c'était un meurtre au premier degré
était un meurtre dans le  troisième
frankie, elle a simplement laissé tomber un homme
comme un chasseur laisse tomber un oiseau, elle a tué
cet homme
mais il lui a
bien fait du tort la première fois qu'elle lui a tiré dessus, il a
chancelé
la prochaine fois qu'elle lui a tiré dessus, il est tombé la
dernière fois qu'elle lui a tiré dessus oh seigneur il
y avait un nouveau  le visage de l'homme en enfer elle a
tué cet homme
dieu sait que vous avez mal agi
alors frankie est descendue sur broadway
aussi loin qu'elle pouvait voir
tout ce qu'elle pouvait entendre était un arc à deux cordes
jouant là oh mon dieu
et cette histoire n'a pas de fin
cette histoire ne va que  pour montrer qu'il
n'y a rien de bon chez certains hommes, ils vous feront du
mal
tout comme montre que vous êtes né
voici une chanson sur les deux
personnes les plus dangereuses au monde
qui sont un homme et une femme et les noms
sont frankie johnny
maintenant
frankie et johnny
étaient amants
oh mon dieu comment ils pouvaient aimer
juste vouloir être fidèles l'un à l'autre
tout aussi vrai que les étoiles au-dessus
il était son homme
elle était une bonne femme
comme tout le monde sait qu'elle
a payé cent dollars
pour chaque costume de vêtements de johnny
elle  aimait cet homme
mais il l'a fait
maintenant ce n'était pas un meurtre au premier degré
n'était pas un meurtre au troisième
frankie elle a simplement laissé tomber un homme comme un
chasseur laisse tomber un oiseau elle a tué cet homme
parce qu'il a bien fait une erreur
la première fois qu'elle a tiré  lui, il a
chancelé
la prochaine fois qu'elle lui a tiré dessus, il est tombé la
dernière fois qu'elle lui a tiré dessus oh seigneur il
y avait un nouveau visage d'homme en enfer elle a
tué cet homme
parce qu'il l'a mal fait
alors frankie est descendue sur broadway
aussi loin qu'elle pouvait voir
tout ce qu'elle pouvait  entendre était un arc à deux cordes
jouer là-bas oh mon dieu à toi dans
toute la ville
pauvre john est mort
maintenant cette histoire n'a pas de morale
et cette histoire n'a pas de fin
cette histoire ne fait que montrer qu'il
n'y a rien de bon chez certains hommes ils  je te ferai
du mal tout
aussi sûr que
c'est une chanson d'amour appelée
tu sais bébé ce que je veux de toi tu
sais bébé ce que je veux
de toi
un gros bisou
tu sais bébé
ce que je veux de toi
c'est un câlin
un gros câlin
maintenant je  ne serai pas
trop impatient
j'attendrai
que tu décides
bébé et quand tu auras fini de décider
maintenant laisse ta conscience être ton dieu tu
sais bébé ce que je veux de toi
c'est
maintenant je ne serai pas
trop impatient
j'attendrai
que tu décides
bébé et quand tu as fini de décider
maintenant laisse ta conscience être ton dieu
est
siree
oui oui oui siree eh
bien voici un vieux favori je pense que tu
connais cette chanson ça s'appelle
le blues de l'infirmerie de saint james
c'était
dans
un coin
de la place
ils  servaient des
boissons comme d'habitude
et la foule habituelle était là
à ma gauche grand joe mckenna
et ses yeux étaient rouges injectés de sang
il a tourné son visage vers les gens
ce sont les mots mêmes qu'il a dit
alors que j'étais à l'infirmerie saint james
j'ai vu mon bébé là-bas
étiré une longue longue table blanche
si douce cool et juste
laissez-la partir
laissez-la aller que Dieu la bénisse
où qu'elle soit elle
peut chercher dans ce monde entier
elle ne trouvera jamais un homme plus doux que moi
quand je mourrai s'il vous
plaît enterrez-moi
et mon  haut haut stable
mettre une pièce d'or de 20 sur ma chaîne de montre
tu sais que je suis mort chemin debout
mieux vaut la
laisser aller que Dieu la bénisse
où qu'elle soit
elle peut chercher dans ce
monde entier
elle ne trouvera jamais un homme plus doux que moi
je veux  six tireurs de merde pour être mon pauvre
porteur
trois jolies femmes
pour chanter une chanson
coller une camionnette de jazz sur le wagon de mon cœur
et soulever l'enfer pendant que je me promène
laisse-la partir laisse-la partir que Dieu la bénisse
où qu'elle soit
elle peut fouiller ce monde entier
dessus,
elle ne trouvera jamais un homme plus doux que moi
maintenant les gens que vous avez entendu mon histoire
maintenant que vous avez entendu ma chanson
si quelqu'un devait vous demander de lui
dire que j'ai entendu qu'il allait
mieux,
laissez-la aller que Dieu la bénisse
partout  elle peut être qu'elle
peut chercher dans tout ce vaste monde
elle ne trouvera jamais
un homme plus doux
que
moi